you look scared he should be
it is the end of the world what's
happening he wants to take control of
you it's up to you to resist him
there's a way to save the world and
still survive all you have to do is
choose life did you bring the plans
about that I've decided not to join you
and your cosmic fashion tragedy that
you're in cahoots with then you won't
get your earth back if saving it means
going back to the person Anna used to be
then what the hell is the point you
really have changed look I'm new to this
whole doing the right thing game but you
should really tell your family the truth
not yet
don't want to believe it I'm sorry
you said you here to get me because the
crisis is here
I will be running off there
suger for the biggest crossover ever
we've got your backs places
the CW's crossover event begins Sunday
December 8 presented by boost mobile the
switch that gives you more welcome back
everyone
it's Charlie we have a brand new flash and
crisis on Infinite Earths Trailer
so we'll break it down we're
doing a flash ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your best theory about crisis on
the video so just starting with the
beginning of the footage you probably
noticed a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
all this there's a whole bunch of stuff
going on in this so I'll just try to
break it down one thing at a time
starting with the flash footage so
episode 7 is called the Last Temptation
of Barry Allen but it's a two-part
mid-season finale before they do the
crossover episodes the synopsis just
reads that Barry gets infected with
Ramsey roses black goo and starts
tripping balls on his way to becoming a
version of the negative flash and
because it's Ramsay's consciousness
taking over Barry's body they might use
that to create a TV version of Red Death
everybody wondered how they were going to accomplish red death because they teased
him last season Red Death in the comics
is the combination of a version of
Batman combined with a version of the
flash but Batman's mind takes over the
body of the flash so he's the one that's
running around using the Flash's powers
that's kind of what's going on with
Ramsey Rosa here but it's them doing a
version of negative flash because he was
negative flash during the Ramsey Rosa
bloodwork arc in the flash rebirth
comics so it's a bunch of different
flash characters combined into one thing
for this two-part finale so it sounds
like it's going to be a pretty big deal but
the synopsis also says that Ramsay turns
most of the city into his minions with
that black goo and then the rest of team
flash has to find a way to stop him well
it seems like iris West is going to uncover
the secret behind black hole that'll
spill into the back half of the season
after crisis on Infinite Earths
so you see Barry wake up in a couple
different places in this he's in the
loft watching the blast wave of
antimatter during crisis on Infinite
Earths erasing everything from existence
it's a bit of an easter egg for the
pilot episode when he saw the particle
accelerator exploded and he had the same look on his face as he watched the blast
wave wash over him and then he got his
flash powers this time it's the opposite
of that and it's kind of like the
runaway dinosaur episode or episodes
where he spends the entire episode
inside the Speed Force where you're not
really sure what's real and what's fake
he passes out here this is probably in
the real world then he's back in the
mind space version of his childhood
bedroom I think the last time
this room was in the runaway dinosaur
episode from season 2 when his mother's
speaking to him here trying to help him
it's unclear if she's one of the
speedforce wormhole aliens or if it's
just his own subconscious and he's
speaking to himself using the form of
his mother then he and Ramsey are inside
the Time Vault looking at the future
newspaper
notice that the date on it reads
December 10th that's the actual day in
real life that we will be watching the
flash episode of crisis on Infinite
Earths then Ramsey telling him to choose
life and give over control of his body
in his powers to him although it's
unclear why Ramsey wants the powers of
the flash maybe just to infect and turn
people faster like Ramsey can use him to
run around and put the black goo and
everybody way way faster than he
normally would then this is a big one
he's inside Nora's baby bedroom that's
her crib with her little hand reaching
for the XS symbols spinning above her
iris West is actually writing the actual
article that will become the future
newspaper in the original timeline she
actually wound up winning a Pulitzer
Prize for writing that article but then
there's Barry in real life reaching down
to touch something that might be before
he gets infected for the first time with
that black goo
so remind her about the flash two-part
mid-season finale over the next two
weeks then the crossover starts for
everyone asking where reverse flash is
I'm assuming that he'll either show up
right before the crossover in the
mid-season finale and some sort of post
credits tag or he'll just show up during
the crossover doing something evil and
explain where he's been for the past
couple of months the arrow crisis on
Infinite Earths
scene is sort of a continuation or a
sequel to the Laurel post-credit scene
from last week where the monitor asked
her to betray Oliver Queen
this time she gives them the middle
finger and then tells Oliver and Diggle
LYLAS secret that she's been
double-crossing them working with the
monitor this whole time as the Harbinger
character Lyla has them tranked and
they'll just pick up with that at the
beginning of next week's episode the
whole thing that Laurel was supposed to
do to betray Oliver Queen was steal
these plans when they went to Russia on
their little field trip to steal
plutonium but also she was supposed to
steal plans for a special weapon that
was this big blast wave generator for
the monitor it probably has something to
do with the giant cosmic tuning forks
that they create during the original
comic book crisis on Infinite Earths
they've been assembling a whole bunch of
different parts Oliver was stealing
dwarf star particles for the monitor
for whatever it is that he's building
but like I said it's probably the tuning
forks but the big thing with Laurel this
season is they're trying to turn her
good because she's going to be on the
green arrow in the canaries spin-off TV
show which they just actually said is
going to be set during the future I feel
like if you really enjoy the Future team
arrow characters and those storylines
this season or you really like the
canary characters you'll probably be
down for that new arrow spin-off show
but for now I'm just going to be focusing
on crisis on Infinite Earths stuff
because there's already way too much
stuff to handle between all the
different shows there's going to be a lot
of Easter eggs but don't worry if you
don't follow all the shows I will be
explaining all the Easter eggs as we go
along
the reason stuff they just revealed was
the first look at Tom Welling as
Smallville Superman he was wearing the
flannel on his version of the Kent farm
on Smallville's earth we don't know what
the designation of that is going to be
there were so many people that were
wondering why he's chopping wood with an
actual axe and why he's wearing gloves
people were worried that he lost his
powers my assumption there is that he's
just being nostalgic he's just doing it
because he likes to do it he doesn't
need to wear gloves he could actually
just chop those in half with his hand he
could cut up wood with his laser eyes
but that's typically not something you
would find Superman doing usually he
does stuff the old-fashioned practical
way when he's on the Kent farm as
awesome as it is seeing him play that
character again I'm also really really
hyped up to see what they're doing with
the Kevin Conroy older version of Batman
that's wearing that very Kingdom come
looking Batman harness the whole idea
with his character if he didn't follow
the Kingdom Come storyline or if he
didn't read it is actually awesome so I
would recommend checking it out at some
point that version of Batman was a
little more cynical it was a bit of a
post-apocalyptic environment all the
superheros children in the future
generations just wound up being terrible
the world devolved into chaos so it was
kind of a situation where a lot of the
old guard the classic superheroes from
the Golden Age like Superman Batman
Wonder Woman had to come out of
retirement to kick a whole bunch of ass
so I'm assuming they'll just have a lot
of Easter eggs for Kingdom Come with
this version of Batman maybe a couple of
Batman the Animated Series and Batman
Beyond Easter eggs too just because it
is Kevin Conroy but just because he's
wearing the harness I'm assuming most of
the Easter eggs will be for Kingdom Come
I talked about this recently too because
Brandon rouse Superman becomes Kingdom
comes Superman and there's a lot of
dregg's for his kingdom come origin
story in the last pre-visit they dropped
i'm wondering if his batman is also from
the same earth as brandon rouse superman
you have to remember that even though
superman looks a little bit older he has
those streaks of grey he ages so much
more slowly than other people that he'll
wind up living for thousands and
thousands of years usually why you see
in the future when they do Legion of
super-heroes stories and Superman isn't
fighting with them it winds up being
Superboy in the Legion of super-heroes
it's because Superman has died for some
reason and he's not around anymore but
the whole idea with kingdom comes
Superman is that he's a super man who's
Lois Lane was killed by the Joker in an
attack he became super cynical he went
into seclusion and eventually the other
classic heroes like Batman and Wonder
Woman convinced him to come back and
help kick the asses of all these younger
superheroes that were going crazy
obviously this is all about crisis on
Infinite Earths so you have a lot of
different major DC comic book stories
intersecting so I'll just trying to deal
with all the Easter eggs episode 2
episode as we get them all but let me
know in the comments what are all your
predictions what are you most excited to
see there'll be more trailers probably
in the next week or two so as soon as
they drop new footage I will totally do
videos for that stuff I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post new DC while
you wait for that click here to learn
about the big Joker 2 movie announcement
that happened this morning and click
here for the Star Wars Mandalorian Episode 2
video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!